[Musique]
à
pour les potes parce que j'avais des
potes qui sont encore ici d'ailleurs qui
sont notamment entraîneur pour certains
ici qui m'avait motivé à faire du rugby
n'ont du coup je les ai rejoints et
c'est comme ça que je pensais au but
[Musique]
moi je voulais finir parce que je pense
que ce sera la dernière année pour moi
de rugby donc je voulais finir sûr sûr
sûr une autre une bonne note
ma petite carrière de rugbyman après ses
presque 30 ans de rugby et donc du coup
voilà j'ai voulu relever un dernier
challenge est un des cochons petite
typhaine de charolles mal et proposait
donc de venir le rejoindre puisque la
règle en tant qu'entraîneur et donc
voilà je les ai suivis pour ce dernier
de challenge avant de raccrocher les
crampons
[Musique]
si vos personnages c'est d'essayer
d'être là tous les mâts décès de pommes
blessé c'est de bien préparer
physiquement parce que arriver ce temps
là je me laisse très facilement la récup
ou c'est pas la même
donc du coup voilà c'est cette fois le
maximum de matches possibles voilà